good
[Music]
hello happy friday september 25th
3 gonzález greet me with the most relevant news
of the day last night a group
marched peacefully through the district of
las vegas they ask for changes in
racial justice all this due to the
decision of a jury in the  that none
of the officers will face charges in
the death of periana tyler
changing the subject
clark county school district will keep
distance learning for now in
virtual meeting
district management group agrees to
keep schools closed through
october  health district indicated that
85 students in the district tested
positive for the coronavirus in the week
of September 13 for that reason
school district officials say that
for now it is better to avoid problems and not
reopen educational facilities
the speed of nascar races
reaches  las vegas' this weekend
without an audience in the stands that you
can enjoy  orally thousands
of spectators come to the las vegas motor
speedway to enjoy these events
that start tonight with a
truck race the ex
infinite competition for tomorrow and the big south
point for hand red for sunday
afternoon
another important event is going  to las
vegas' this year due to the pandemic is
the professional bull riders world finals
power that is going to dallas texas
this event was scheduled for
november at the scam wedding queen but
this year it will take place at
the dallas football stadium  cowboys and now
we turn to the temperatures and
the weather forecast for this
weekend today we will have a maximum of 100
degrees with a sunny day and for tomorrow
Sunday we will have a slight drop with
temperatures in the high 90s I
wish you a great weekend
andrés gonzález informed them and this was about
the indignant news in Spanish
[Music]